[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance to Donald Trump
my father died seven years ago March 13
2010 he died after seven months in
hospitals and six months in the surgical
intensive care unit and after a fight
against death so extraordinary but it
caused the chief of that unit to mistake
him for a professionally trained athlete
when in fact he hadn't exercised since
1951 and when I told him about it my dad
laughed even though there was a
breathing tube down his throat he died
with my sister and I having to make the
decision to let him go and he died with
her holding his hand and me reading him
his favorite James Thurber story and him
I swear waiting until this very long
story was over and only then profoundly
sighing and leaving us he died leaving
me a hospital bill for six months of 24
hour-a-day surgical intensive care
another month in standard care one
four-hour long operation and thousands
of procedures and scans and drugs and
consultations he left me a bill if I
remember correctly of approximately
$1,000 and most of that was for a
television he had rented for a few days
early on my father had a little private
policy and something he got for being in
the army and government issued insurance
Trump a thing called Medicare our
out-of-pocket costs for his stays in the
hospital about $5 a day he died after
seven months in which we talked every
day as the debate raged around us and as
we could hear the practical impact it
had on the lives and finances of the
other patients and families in that
hospital of what was then called health
care reform or insurance reform and
which shortly after my dad's death
became known as the Affordable Care Act
and less officially Obamacare Obamacare
which Trump you idiot and that idiot
Ryan and this liar price and that liar
Chaffetz now want to undo because
confronted with an independent
calculation that repeal by your
Republicans will end insurance for at
least 15 million
Americans and asked how many will lose
their coverage under this plan this
sniffling little man Ryan who sucks up
to you says quote I can't answer that
question
it's up to people people are going to do
what they want to do with their lives
because we believe in individual freedom
in this country individual freedom like
the freedom to die because you don't
have health insurance the way roughly
122 Americans died because they didn't
have health insurance every day before
the ACA was passed as my father was
dying
individual freedom Trump go to hell Paul
Ryan
individual freedom Trump like freedom
from taxes for the rich the Joint
Committee on taxation which is a
nonpartisan are Matt crunches numbers
for Congress calculated that the
Republican gutting of health care that
you are leading Trump will in the next
decade reduce the taxes of those making
a million or more a year by one hundred
and fifty seven billion dollars
individual freedom Trump or is this
condescending jackass Chaffetz put it
quote Americans have choices and they've
got to make a choice
so maybe rather than getting that new
iPhone that they just love and want to
go spend hundreds of dollars on maybe
they should invest in their own health
care the price of an iPhone would not
cover those few days my father rented
that hospital television nevermind
something like cancer drugs or surgery
or the price you are actually billed to
have your father officially declared
dead
go to hell jason Chaffetz individual
freedom Trump like the freedom to end
the insurance of 700,000 new Medicaid
recipients added just since the reform
of 2010 just in Ohio per the Republican
governor there John Kasich kicked them
off and it said throw them an insurance
tax credit of $3,000 and as Kasich asks
rhetorically what kind of insurance
you're going to buy for $3,000 that's
individual freedom or as this liar and
con man your Health and Human Services
Secretary Tom Price put it quote I
firmly believe that
nobody will be worse off financially and
of course trumpet he's right
if by nobody he means insurance
companies and Republican donors and the
wealthy go to hell Tom Price individual
freedom Trump like your budget director
insisting you are focused on health care
not insurance coverage as if when they
hand you your bill at your hospital or
your doctor's office you could hand it
back and say ha I'm not focused on care
I'm not focused on paying you Trump you
said on September 27th 2015 quote
everybody has got to be covered I'm
going to take care of everybody Trump
you said on February 19 2016 quote
you're gonna end up with great health
care for a fraction of the price and
that's gonna take place immediately
Trump you said this on January 15th of
this year quote we're going to have
insurance for everybody
only now your budget director says
because you Trump you don't have the
courage to say it yourself
that quote insurance for everybody that
means health care not insurance which
means nothing which means everybody
you're on your own
go to hell Trump months before my dad
died seven years ago the likelihood that
he would became tangible to me and in
that hospital every day twice a day as
we talked about that and we talked about
health care reform it began to dawn on
me what we were all really debating I
wrote much of what follows here in
October 2009 it is true again because of
you Trump since you evidently think you
are immortal have a sane grown-up person
explained to you what this next part
means this ultimately is about death
about preventing it about fighting it
about resisting it about grabbing hold
of everything and anything to forestall
it and postpone it even though we know
that the force will overcome us all
always will always has healthcare is at
its core about improving the odds of
life in its struggle against death of
extending that game which we will all
lose
each and every one of us on to Eternity
extending in another year or month or
second this is the primary directive of
life the essence of our will as human
beings and when we go to a doctor's
office or a hospital or a storefront
clinic in a ghetto we are expressing
this fundamental cry of humanity I want
to live I want my child to live I want
my wife to live I want my father to live
I want my neighbor to live I want that
stranger I do not know and never will
know to live and there is the essence of
what this is what on the eternal list of
priorities precedes health what more
obvious role could government have than
the defense of the life of each citizen
we cannot stop every germ that seeks to
harm us any more than we can stop every
person that seeks to harm us but we can
try dammit and governments essential
role in that effort facilitate it reduce
its costs broaden its availability
improve my health and yours seems
ultimately self-explanatory we want to
live what is government for if not to
help us to do so I issue this morning to
your Trump take these steps and you will
inherit the wind gut health care in this
country so millionaires can save 16
billion a year in taxes and you will be
killing American citizens and before we
let you do this Trump we will defend
ourselves protests nonviolent resistance
good a mass refusal to pay insurance
premiums perhaps risky a general strike
against this country yes shut the
country down rather than let you kill
people health care Trump is about life
and death and right now you are on the
side of death and we will not permit
this resist peace